[Música]
quem é vivo sempre aparece aí boatos
pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark sejam
muito bem vinda é mais um vídeo pessoal
e hoje nós vamos jogar um couro
há quem não perceba um inglês foi
motivada por um jogo de rua por não
tê-la no instagram os fãs que estavam
revoltados e gravata rua e muita gente
respondeu que sim então o reconhecimento
de voz e seguirem este grêmio porque lá
faz muitas perguntas então vocês podem
servir no ar o que o be está aqui no
canal
hoje nós vamos jogar um ex-clube eo mal
que seu uso de michael jackson possuído
com o capitão dentro do estojo é gre nal
segunda fim de sua base que montou um
jogo no michael jackson também traz nos
com os dentes de seus filhos vai ser
assustadora eu vou ficar aqui com
certeza mas mas antes de usarmos aqui
espero que só eu quero anunciar aqui que
vai estrear dia 23 com o milestone bem
23 de maio ela nenhuma obrigado disney é
obrigado portugal nos tons clássicos e
estruturais tudo em imagens que as muito
obrigado é o filme sedação cheia de
magia tudo que dizem que o empresário
está lá e adivinhem só quem é que é um
génio gênio é um mito basicamente um
poço de isto para isto então já falam só
o dia 23 mas não perco uma no cinema e
quem sabe a gente não se encontra lá no
cinema ou eu fico lá você espera outro
lado como pipoca possua ó espera por mim
vocês pudessem finalizavam os anjos com
o gênio do menino que fosse o diabo é é
só comentei nos comentários que agora
vamos lá na época tinha dor agora eu
preferi escolher em inglês mas eu acho
que busca o espanhol porém muito mais
graça nem de onde estou e que lugar é
esse que tem que encontrar uma forma de
essa lei humana quer que será nome de
raça credo ou estudar menção estou
escutando com 11 cadeiras de hidratação
do meu ouvido e nada a ver com o walkman
ok eu acho que eu preciso fazer uma
empresa aqui né
o que show incrível realidade virtual
adora tecnologia 2019 só vai valer como
foi um sono foi discriminado aumenta em
um sonho hotel no figurino
inscreva-se no canal está muito alto até
o sul após demissões também deus no meu
opposing tarp criado
estou pedindo já eu não tenho muita
orientação
são 1 creio que necessita olhar p é
preciso uma chave então vamos lá ver
green
é daí que vem a música é este o caminho
não conseguiu ligar o cabo será com o
ioc sob o toque ea união européia
permite ao usuário fica assim mais caro
um surdo de mais fácil estratégias meus
amigos têm gestores irão ajudar praça
joão távora
ai ai meu curta pelo júri a partir de
agora é coroa é não haver sinal vermelho
sinal vermelho está tendo este
prognóstico só vale se o nuclear que
necessita olhava e outra em árabe
tanto é assim que o povo está muito alto
ea intenção do qual o poder deixou um
tac dentro vocês não têm noção em 2005 e
sabe passar um cheque pessoal vocês vão
ver nesses 21 de junho
é porque eu vou tá com cara de bunda é
sempre tudo pronto e eu tenho
equipamentos game mais só de marca é
muito burro
ok vamos com calma
basta mesa após poço
é coisa séria de empréstimo num rock por
dia mas é um bicho estranho a área
ocultado ernesto voltar a pulsar é outra
assim não sabe que vocês mandam que o
col endurecida produto assim ta phut no
quintal terá vez e agora que isto tem um
homem enforcado num só contrário time
focado fazer o pino olho nos morrem
assim já aposta em uma cravada o som do
yuck em molho vai embora é o povo sumiu
de jesus a chamá-lo de mora ou eu falo
eu estava a correr num como s rock em um
ritual
op o meu curva eu não como está lá agora
[Música]
3018 muito profissional e olha só o
desafio é é só o que eu faço o que eu
faço aqui não só eu vou ficar a olhar
para a strange belta perna mesa é que
antiquada século 18 eu não sei o que vou
fazer não só eu quero ver o que é isto
o hu tem a cara do rock beer e eu
consigo saber que não vamos continuar
enfrentando agora muito festa como quem
não quer coisas
laporta está bloqueada e se tornou para
as cargas para quem passar caso esta
braço que existe uma tela do pt talvez
eu sei vamos tentar e o o 1
as coisas estão aqui no meu quarto
as coisas por foi campeã prefeita coisa
no ar eu não sei
já percebi porque é que vocês gostem de
ver os garis das coisas ou chegou cheia
o jeito o cheta ao certo o cheque ao
chefe cantil mikati we walk
olha o comércio local para trás eu nem
sei se eu vir aí existe uma estratégia
aqui eu vou perceber a estratégia e eu
vou eu vou passar este jogo agora é só
vocês ouvirem muitas décadas é porque
tem tem homens lá furacão destruiu uma
casa é que eu lá então eu peço imensa
desculpa mas eu não consigo controlar
disse lowe é preciso encontrar um sítio
para esconder o ovo
nunca posso falar nem tentar o que
queremos dizer agora eu já vi
ou melhor outra virou tavira opel o
[Música]
grupo tapa dentro já agora agora em todo
o planeta é muito rápido caraças
[Música]
ae
luxa está aqui todo mundo tava mãe o meu
deus que o partido vive um momento bom
porque não nos acompanhe agora prazer
que me a tomar é o palhaço todo mundo
mas eu tenho culpa que olhou no meu deus
meu corpo está a salvo uma chave a a a
depor hoje eu tenho que colocar uma hora
específica qual é a hora que eu tenho
por aqui consegui aqui também dá pra
escolher a final
meu deus estou a ficar quente chance
gols
será que as 33 hora do capeta três em
três horas
é isto o checo acrescentar eu nem sabia
elson gênio
[Música]
o primeiro viu seguro nem burro ou em
outro
[Música]
perguntado hero mudar muita raiva dá
muita muita muita raiva já tem apenas
chávez espera que este guarda as coisas
eu espero que o senhor volte a instalar
o que vocês fizeram um jogo vamos
instalar isto não tem mais fronteiras
longe
ela tem que mais coisas é o peu é um
pouquinho mesmo a ganhar forma uma casa
já olhou atingiu caraças
a modelo foi dado por valdir homens a
[ __ ] walkman é tão poderoso como justa
câmara tem programado meus qualquer
pessoa quando fica por aqui construí
vocês já puderam ver que nem consegui
passar o jogo né você tem que começar a
recomendar jogos que consegui passar
assim não dá
o senhor não vai aguentar muito forte
enfim pessoal pois muitos não sabe o que
está um vídeo de humor com vocês tanto
pela voz vocês têm aqui o vosso amigo
que havia antigamente quando fazia muito
terror investir pra eu manipulo whatsapp
e digam que o dark frango vai começar a
trazer mais terror mas só se vocês
assistirem porque não tirem aí não quer
fumar e se o airton é maneira que eu não
posso viver a ensino brasileira amanhã
até a próxima